we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
yeah hey
folks here we are we might be drunk
looks like we got a nice bag of hooch
on the table i don't know what it is i'm
excited how you been fatty
i'm good man my neck is still a little
out but i'm you know i'm hanging in
there
you wanted white wine yes i wanted red
wine
compromise one in the middle
little orange look at that bad boy
that's a good looking bottle there
look at that i say it's good at the
store so we'll see we got natty wine
baby
wow a little day drink hold on it's got
like a uh
pop top like a beer yeah we'll see if
it's good
oh you hear that folks see what we're
doing here this is funky
please do the honor
yes it's it's the day as usual we've
been doing a lot of day
apps but oh yeah bring it on
that cup's bigger so factor that in all
right
so is that is that even that's probably
about right
oh god you know what i don't know if i'm
becoming a raging alcoholic or what but
i was like am i looking forward to the
pod to see you or i'm like i want a
drink
it's like a beautiful day out that's 75
degrees
it smells pretty good
he's got a kick sally's here oh that is
like weird
two seconds in that's like grapefruity
oh he's pissed
oh man that's good yeah that's good
stuff damn
this is gonna sound bad but i like it i
like it a lot
it tastes kind of like when you drink
orange juice and then brush your teeth
or when you brush teeth then drink
orange juice it has that kick
there's a somalia punching a wall
somewhere yeah no but it's great
no it is good man no i know what you
mean it's kind of got that like kind of
bitterness
yes yes but i'm into it we're learning
we're learning new words we were talking
to our uh
our christopher arai uh right guy our
right guy
yeah and he said do not use the word
smooth it's hack
so uh aromatic floral
yes oaky fruity
fruity effervescent can we say fruity i
don't think so
fruity's out that's [ __ ] good
this podcast is just gonna devolve like
two weeks from now we're just [ __ ]
we're just hammered one of us is on the
floor i'm like this is
a good episode yeah yeah
oh yeah well this is great uh so much to
tell i had i had a good afternoon sex
wrong you do oh my god i'm in high
spirits the sun is shining i'm drinking
we're here
we're queer it's great um uh we don't
want any more beer
no who needs it when we got this stuff
but uh me and the lady went out to lunch
the hard part about having a gal a
girlfriend for a while is like
initiating because you feel so stupid
like all right you want to go in there
cause
the art of seduction when you're single
is like such a process the drinking the
food
the walk the hand holding oh she touched
my knee i'm in you know
it's such a whole thing but with a
girlfriend you're like ah you want to go
in there and
knock this out real quick then you just
kind of you just kiss him you start kind
of going for it right
i guess but i'm not big into kissing
come on
and uh i just pick her up and throw her
in there like yeah
man yeah because i'm just like i don't
want to do the whole rigmarole you know
and i think she's kind of into it but uh
have one of those romps you know usually
you jizz in two seconds or she never
gets off or she gets off and you don't
but it was one of those perfect ones
where we both got off
you said you jizz in two seconds i'm
like how do you know my sex life
well i think that's most dudes it's hard
yeah if i mean if you're doing the
condom if it's one thing if you don't
doing the condom you're kind of like all
right this is
this ain't gonna last i know i know the
relationship
but uh yeah no it's uh it's tough man
it's it's tough to
for everyone to get what they want and
like yes this is gonna sound really
[ __ ] up
please but i feel like now like when we
were kids i feel like women didn't
always expect to come
i think you're right and now i think and
it's like good for them you should be
coming i'm with you
but i'm just saying you know i'm like oh
[ __ ] sex has changed like sometimes like
i'll be [ __ ] the whole time and i'm
just like well i'm not into this
yeah but she is so i'm just you know
like the position i mean you know yeah
yeah completely completely so you go
with it for her
yeah because it helps her i i dated the
gal once she had to get on top and like
i guess my dick was too small for her
because he would have to like wiggle to
find it
like she gets a running start yeah she
shoots out of a cannon
right she's right so i had to just wait
there while she's like
you know doing all these movements and i
was like all right like she looked like
an idiot but
she did what you had to do to get off i
guess
and uh yeah i'm all for it i feel like
as comics if you don't get her off
you're you're bombing
yeah no you gotta you gotta you gotta
get them off yeah yeah
so we got the vibrator next to the bed
just really oh yeah cause i don't wanna
leave her hanging what's your bit about
that again
oh about how like she'll use it in front
of me and like she's like moaning and
i'm just sitting there and i'm like
i feel obsolete i feel like the employee
at cvs and she's using the self-checkout
oh that's strong
thank you thank you that's a good bit
man thanks yeah did it last night
but uh yeah but great romp
she i had the legs up she's on her back
going for it and then uh she got off and
then i
was like thank god and i got off right
after it is funny that sex a lot when
you get older it's just like
it's just like thank god she came yes
yes exactly because now i can
yeah yeah that's true you're right it's
very i don't want to say mechanical but
you you you you're efficient yeah
you're almost like a point guard you're
just trying to get you're just trying to
get her open
you're just trying to get like all right
thank god i got out of the ball yeah
exactly my work here is done yeah yeah
so
everybody scored no traveling uh double
dribble
copper chin but all right there we go
she had a good time and then she can
just get back to work you know she works
from home so
oh man she's finished that zoom call
well that feels like a like a power move
that you left on
you see tuban's back on cnn i saw that
and that gal
brought it up immediately oh i know well
you have to
i get but she's like such want to make
sure and he's like yes that's correct
she's like okay i had to get that out it
was it was less like the elephant in the
room and more like you've been a very
bad boy
yes exactly like we all know what this
is what are you crazy
you got monica lewinsky on you're not
like let me check the dress okay
you're good i do kind of sound weird but
i kind of feel bad for the guy
i totally feel bad for the guy what are
you kidding me i mean it wasn't like he
did it as like a power move
he did it it's like [ __ ] i'm an old man
who doesn't know technology
and was was he rubbing it out or was he
in the underwear what was it i think it
was jerking off
okay so he didn't know it was on oh yeah
no i or he thought his i mean i would
hope he just thought the call was over
and not that he thought
i mean maybe this guy's got a really
busy schedule and he's got to rub one
out while they're like he's like well
you know it's dark
right right he's between calls yeah yeah
yeah but
i don't know i don't think he did
anything devious and
yeah and we gotta start or we gotta stop
getting mad at people for doing [ __ ] we
all do
we all do that we all jerk off front of
our computer or men do anyway
it's like i know he [ __ ] up but he
didn't mean to do that
you know it's like when a guy slips and
says a bad word
you know it's like a guy's like the
[ __ ] in the arm and it was like you're
going to jail
yeah but that guy who got fired for that
on cnn like that or espn who did the
chicken yeah
thing about jeremy lin like that that's
a that's a phrase it's a complete fact
and espn published it i know so it's
like you're only you're only mad
once you guys all got in trouble you
know what's interesting is uh
good point tuban if anything it's the
pandemic's fault because that's
that chair became his workshop good
point that's the chair you used to jack
the chair is the evil thing not him
all right because your body associates
that chair with jerking it and
working it yes so you have to it's gonna
it's gonna get
the the lines are gonna get crossed
every now and then you know yeah it was
weird to see him on there but also like
man i gotta admit i'm a fan of the guy's
writing like i love
really i mean the patty hearst books
phenomenal he wrote the oj book
what yeah he's written some of the best
books i think i love tuban man
yeah i mean i didn't even know that he
got fired from the new yorker cnn kept
them
for them good for them it would have
been great though if we just started
jerking off on air and they're like yeah
we should go we got to fire yeah
but i mean the new yorker what's a more
new york thing than jerking off in
public
new yorkers should have kept them if you
started cat calling on the zoom call
they should have promoted them
i'll tell you that yeah exactly oh
man well good for toby i'm glad he's
still still kicking
and that's just your legacy now that
sucks for the guy
it was humiliating he's gotta go to
every family reunion every pta meeting
uh every you know church thing i hate
date dubs
yeah we all know every time he turns
around yeah
exactly that's that's who you are now
it's like you know so
i yeah whatever i mean but i mean i
can't wait to meet the guy because i'm
gonna be like hey quit jerking me around
you know you gotta
you're gonna shake his hand yeah well
look i'm shaking your hand i know you're
jerked off
you know it's like that little joke i
used to have by the guy who goes uh
the homophobic guy is like i'm not
shaking a gay man's hand you know me
dixie's touch like you don't think a
woman is blowing a guy or had a dick in
her vagina so that's all out oh that's a
good point
yeah we i think we had a lot of we had
more gay jokes when we started out
because
i felt like that there was more
intolerance so it was more of an
interesting topic
so true and it kind of shifted now to
trans people
yeah and i've got a i got a ton of trans
stuff now i used to have a gay bet
a guy said gay sex isn't natural but
it's not sex for the purpose of
reproduction i was like
no sex i've ever had was for the purpose
of reproduction great bit
yeah you [ __ ] the couch yeah you go
yeah it's against nature and i say i
[ __ ] couch cushions
so i'm in no position to judge anyone
what they're doing yeah man well you
both used to have a lot of gay jokes had
a lot of gay yeah we were we were
attacking the
the bigotry in a way but
that was a long one but we kept it funny
you got to keep well you can't those
comics that go up there and just pander
you're just like enough
new york is getting rough for these
shows i got to tell you like yeah
i don't know you felt like i mean
salaccus is here with us now and he
he uh he watched me eat a fat one in one
show but then
it's funny we always shout on the
tourists like these tourists we're in
the shows
that you need a mix of the taurus and
the new yorkers because they're all new
yorkers at these seller shows
yeah they're not great no they're ooh
and on and it's about perception
i can't be seen laughing at that joke
yeah i can't be seen like they're a
[ __ ] politician and they just got
busted
i know but i tap in toes in the men's
room
i think that's what the internet is done
though it's like oh that's my
it goes back to my point and look we
don't want to get dive into this [ __ ]
but it goes back to my point of
uh oh [ __ ] i forgot my point hold on
damn it the natural wine it's good wine
man
what was my point earlier about the uh
oh
we're getting mad and and judging people
on [ __ ] we do
we all have [ __ ] up thoughts we all
have twisted weird that's what comedy is
great for
is calling that [ __ ] out and you go i i
do that it's relatable if anything it
should be a moment where we connect with
people it should be like
it's a vulnerable moment exactly like
that is
instead of not me that's you man that's
all you like oh yeah i'm the only person
who's
[ __ ] up here come on yeah my brother
will say this and i was like we don't
need to be more
accepting but we do need to be more
forgiving yes
you know and that goes for like
everything everything
my girl always says i'd rather a honest
pig
than a dis like those weird male
feminist guys or you're like what are
you hiding
yeah you know like give me a regular out
of the gate
you know like sexist jerk off guy she'd
rather that guy than the the weirdo
hiding something
well at least he's not at least you know
who that person is like honesty
is better than like a sneaky creep yes
yes
because we know those dudes who are like
those loud and proud like
feminist type guys but then then we're
like we hear murmurs about them on the
road yeah yeah
okay exactly so you're overcompensating
it's like the politician that we all see
who's like gays they're demons
they're demons and then they find out
they're like you know they're a regular
some bar called the glory hole
all right and he's like i'm patriotic
you see that picture of ted cruz hugging
the flag oh yeah that was fun
that was weird yeah it's getting weird
it's getting weird where it's like
just just be a person no not everything
has to be so performative
yes yeah performative that's exactly
that's what everybody's doing they're
performing they're performing it's all
about perception
anyway i'll be at the uh i'll be at
tampa this weekend yeah
no speaking of performing yeah we're
performative
yeah but that's you know that's what you
come see us for we're not politicians
folks
no no no thank god yeah but that's
that's rough because your whole thing is
like
like you see these political ads and
every ad is like this person said this
one time
yeah and you're like that's the attack i
know i know it's crazy
i i i can't get behind anybody who's
like obsessed
with paul like the way you are with the
knicks some people are like that with
some politician i'm like they're all
lying like i know some are maybe better
than others but
you can't tell me they're all honest
yeah fanaticism
is dangerous yes i mean whether you're a
fan of a sport like look i'm a knicks
fan but you saw that video that went
viral the suns fan beating the [ __ ] out
yeah
that was [ __ ] hilarious that was
great it was funny because those nuggets
fans got
like we don't want to fight we don't
want to fight and then they [ __ ]
cheap shot him and it was a big dude he
just started to win
he looked like he'd been a lot of fights
he's uh he's a florida guy
and he had a mullet a phoenix guy a
phoenix guy sorry
same [ __ ] though west coast florida
that's great tweet that but he did the
hockey move where he
grabbed the guy's uh jersey and kept him
down he was just doing it
like 10 times in the face i think he
broke his nose the best part
is when after the guy runs away he goes
sons and four to the guys
sons and four yeah so he's beating the
[ __ ] out of him and then
doing the sports talk that started it to
rub it in the guy runs away
and then he does this he poses it was
like a wrestling heel
i know i know and then the cops came and
he didn't move he's like i'm watching
the game they hit me first
that was great and then devin booker
from the suns when they won vote get me
that guy's address so maybe he's sending
him a you know star of the sun's maybe
he's sending him like a gift
that's amazing i'm sure they all love
that guy i would love him
i mean if that guy was at our show
beating up a heckler i'd be like give me
that guy's address
i'm sending him a t-shirt are you a
friend of ours louis gomez once i
remember you were on stage
do you remember this story i do i do you
were getting heckled and you dealt with
it
as best you could for a while but at a
certain point the guy was just not
at some point you can't tell a joke when
the guy is heckling like that and lewis
walks up to the guy and goes
[ __ ] yeah and the guy's like what yeah
but he won't stop and lose goes outside
yeah and the guy's like all right so the
guy goes outside i'm watching this like
you know oh this is beautiful i followed
them outside to watch what's happening
yeah
in front of the guy's girlfriend lewis
goes [ __ ]
and the guy's like ah and he backs down
it was like
yeah well that's what [ __ ] it was
justice in a while of course of course
and i didn't know louis at the time he
was just like he's a comic i'm a comic
[ __ ] this guy and you know he wants to
fight people so uh i had met the world
to me we were interested friends after
that
i was like i'm glad that guy's on our
side oh my god the puerto rican
rattlesnake
yeah he he's uh that's a genuine guy he
keeps it real
oh yeah i remember one time he used to
book lol comedy club like back in the
day or like maybe his girlfriend but i
think b book did
but uh uh anyway
the guys running it were just kind of
[ __ ] running the club
and they were they got mad at me once
because that you could never find them
to get your money was that [ __ ] where
like you were always if you're like hey
can i get paid they'd be like
i'm in the middle of something yes
exactly they're being like a phone call
i'm i'm dealing with something so anyway
um yeah
uh-huh right and you're just like ah gee
come on so i remember i was like
i got another spot i just i know you're
gonna forget to pay me if i if i don't
get it tonight yeah
and and the guy was like he can't work
here anymore he always wants his money
it was like the thing
like he always like rude about who wants
his money i was like i wasn't rude i was
like i just need
the money now i know and uh and lewis
like no that's what comics do
that's what real comics do they have
other spots so like he just they had my
back in that way i was like that's a
good guy
we love you lou yeah yeah that's why you
can see a great club they pay you when
you walk in
like the seller you walk in you sign the
thing if they don't pay you they find
you they
you never have to ask at the seller it's
so it's so weasley that when places like
they try to avoid giving you your money
you're 20
or whatever we're there for yeah or like
you know it's funny
how often have we been paid like like
we're like
low level drug uh on the corner drug
dealers
like greasy greasy just smack it in like
i had a guy used to pay me be like he'd
like look around before paying me i'm
like this is legal why are you like
looking around well maybe it's not
maybe it's off the books or something
but yeah yeah i mean have you been
shorted before
yeah of course i've been short on the
road many times and then they're like no
you got to read the email i'm like oh
maybe i do
and then i read the email and i'm like
ah it's 200 bucks less yeah
something that doesn't happen anymore
really but back in the day having a
manager helps
i was in ac uh last weekend and i had
been there many years ago
and the guy just disappeared and he owed
other people way more money than me
but damn i mean he just disappeared wow
i did a fest
i'm not gonna say which one and our
agent we the same age at the time
she got my money first she's like he'll
come
and this fest looks amazing and the
lineup was amazing but
she's like i want the money now and
they're like well we're gonna pay
everybody after and
she's like i want it now and nobody else
got paid
you got paid i got paid yeah damn and i
felt bad like why are you bothering
these guys now that that's not how they
do they just stiffed every other comment
they just ran out of money they just
couldn't afford it
they went too hard on the fest did you
do the fire fest
no i wish but uh ja rules booking man
it's [ __ ] it's a it's a fire lineup
man that was a crazy duck that was crazy
i really enjoyed they
remember they had two i didn't see the
hula one i heard that one was better it
was good
i watched them both watch them both i
did i was pandemic i watched netflix and
i was like this is all i need to know
about this
you got the gist there's been a weird uh
trend of like
slimy hot white guys who like was he hot
that guy
ah he's hot enough billy mcfarland he's
a handsome guy full head of hair
tall you know big smile hot enough
he passes the test what about the wework
guy
gorgeous tall he's like six five full
head of hair sally pull up the wework
guy if you can
i'm not connected do you see my image up
there no i
gotta talk to big matt we'll figure that
out damn but the wework guy that's a
great deal i want to see what he looks
like
oh my god he looks like vinnie chase
from entourage
but taller vinnie chase that was a
handsome man smoke show
yeah vinny worst character on the show
though
yeah kind of nothing nothing there
boring and
it's always like i'm a great actor i'm
like you're not even good in these
scenes
everyone else is so good on the show
yeah dylan was amazing oh my god kevin
dylan he steals it
he's oh yeah that dude's a handsome guy
oh man he's like uh what do you call it
like um
scandinavian or something yeah no the
rest of the acting on that show is like
insane
yeah kevin dillon is so funny so good i
i watched the first two probably first
three episodes today i was bored
i'll be checking out entertainment good
we were talking about it hadn't seen it
in 20 years
it is so great the whole time you're
watching they can't do that now couldn't
do that now four white guys
four like white guys it's beyond four
white guys
it's more than that they can't do
anything all in all they care about is
getting [ __ ]
uh making money they're like should we
get the rolls should we get the rolls
turtles like get the rolls i'm gonna get
blown all day
and they're like yeah they slap a girl
in the ass i mean it's crazy they should
do that show about a white movie star
living recklessly now and he's like we
spent it all on the bentley and his
agents like
there's no other parts that's it that's
all you had
that's true yeah it's wild yeah because
it's like these young new york guys from
queens and hollywood and it's a great
premise
it's great it's it's definitely it's
definitely like
it's how basic are we talking about uh
it's very basic that's
about entourage right now but yeah i
mean that whole that was basically sex
in the city for dudes that's what it was
now let me ask you this and this is
gonna get dicey but
it's weird that now that was trendy then
that was those were cool guys you know
they were
flashy and confident and curse words and
all this [ __ ]
but it's interesting that now
it's the exact opposite is cool like
respecting women
and uh being vegan and not really
getting [ __ ] up
and all that is cool now so it's weird
that that's
cool like it's weird that that took over
because we're all we all want those
other things deep down you just have to
pretend we don't it's like the
performative thing
yeah that's a good point and also but i
also feel like entourage was done like
the reason they got away with it is
because the loyalty of just being good
to your boys that's like
why they got away with a lot of that
like interesting you knew that you knew
vince as annoying as he was
was like um that's the dream it's like
male porn you're just right
male porn we still i still like other
porn but uh
it's uh no but it was like it was like
fantasy for men because
it's just like you may one of your
friends makes it he just takes you along
for the ride
and like the stakes became absurd later
in this it's like it's like [ __ ] is is
turtle going to be worth 3 million or 6
million
yeah that was the big like twist of the
next episode but it was still
fun yeah there he goes but it was
interesting because there's a lot of
female
actor like sarah silverman's in episode
three right and
jimmy kimmel's in it but there's jessica
alba and there's all these other uh
female debbie mazar is in it oh dude
she's the best she's great
i love her but uh you can tell the women
are going with it like like jessica
apple's like boys you showed up there's
some hot chicks over there i think you
can [ __ ] one you're like oh wow you're
like enabling
you know it's so weird to hear a woman
talk like that
but yeah i mean a lot i think like the
goal post has definitely been moved in
yeah oh yeah no doubt about it no doubt
about it i mean you talk about like how
it's cool to be him i used to do a bit
about
uh i did it and two specials ago about
how uh
you know back in the day like the 80s
best friend was always like uh you know
the scholarship oh yeah but now they're
gonna have to make like the like the
good
like man we didn't hook up we just
talked he's like well sometimes
that's really important too you know
like that's what the movies are gonna be
now
yeah but that guy exists that's what i
don't get that
scumbag guy exists so yeah but now you
have to
now it's funny with like they're just
covering their bases like all these big
companies like hbo netflix amazon hulu
they're covering their assets you can't
have a funny [ __ ] anymore like do you
think you could actually make a show
with like kenny powers nowadays
that's a good question that's what i
don't get i think now you have to be
like
here's the character yeah but you need
someone being like this
is wrong like this is really i mean the
beauty of eastbound down is everyone is
kind of looking at him like you're a
[ __ ] he's an idiot you're an idiot
but like could you even have he's got a
rebel flag
boogie board you i don't know if you
could do that anymore i mean the joke is
like this guy is so ignorant yeah
i think that still plays if you ask me
and i think
the first guy to redo it is that's going
to be a hit i read an interview once
with danny
mcbride and they were like are you like
kenny powers at all and then he was like
no and then like later in the interview
he said there was a story where he
pantsed his girlfriend
you totally are like kenny powers a
little bit yeah it's gotta be a little
but look at all in the family one of the
greatest sitcoms of all time
norman lear it's about this guy who's a
living in queens he's a bigot he's an
old irish guy
he hates blacks and puerto ricans and
megan's fun makes fun of him all day
long he calls his son a hippie get a
haircut
that that show would never exist now
because they're like ah he's not likable
or he's so mean you're like yeah yeah
but that's the joke
that's what scares me is like i know
we're trying to
be progressive and move on but to me
that is progressive
he's the he's the he's the butt well
you're complaining that a character is
not represented
yes that you think exists but they don't
want to give they don't want to give
shine to that type of person
right yeah they think they're maybe
complicit
i think that the fear of being complicit
is so
so big that we're losing out on good art
is what i'm saying
i think i think you're completely right
all right i think i think
you make a great point and uh i think
they'll do it in a drama but with comedy
for some reason yes
yeah because i guess you're making light
of it but that's the whole point of
comedy
is to make light of [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
i mean stan hope did that great bit
like you had like they they got mad at
him from making fun of something and he
goes
how could you ruin the word make fun uh
like how could you find the bad and make
fun that's great yeah i mean i love that
i mean
yeah i think drama here's the problem i
think dramas are just taken more
seriously than comedy
oh no doubt about it i mean look at the
oscars like yeah comedy is never
respected so i think that plays a big
role
totally well you're like if this is if
we're
showing this horrible character we can
we can be like oh this is tragic but you
can't really do that with comedy some
comedies can do it like
i thought fleabag was pretty good at
that i love fleabags yeah great show
great show and i think she was kind of a
like a degenerate in a way she would
[ __ ] random guys she was an alcoholic
women can get away with that's what i
was going to say because women can do it
because they never made shows like that
about because it's new
it's nick like schumer trainwreck is
just like i don't want a relationship i
want to get drunk i want to [ __ ] a bunch
of guys
and you're like yeah yeah that was our
thing but because it's
a lady now it's it's new again right you
know
which is kind of goes against the whole
thing of like
we're all equal we're all the same it's
like well
if we're all the same then how come when
she does it it's different well i think
because
as i just said it hasn't been done
hasn't been done so it's like you know
i've had this talk with women who've
said you know we didn't
we you watch a lot of like 90s movies
and stuff you're like women get a lot of
boring ass roles
bad role they're all finally they're
getting cool roles yes and it's for a
long time women have gotten into those i
agree
i agree i'm talking like ancient [ __ ]
grease long like
yeah like eventually like classic comedy
strata it's about
how like the women won't [ __ ] the men
until they end the war which is like a
hilarious premise for
a comedy but it's also like that's a
[ __ ] that's a meaty role
not tonight no
you're totally right but uh i just don't
think we should
lose the man one like why take one away
why can't you have both yeah no i agree
with that i think uh i think
it's it's like it doesn't it does
country so let's get rid of the whites
well i think uh i i think there's a
dishonesty with like major
networks yeah who are just like we wanna
we wanna
i mean i was listening to this uh
this podcast about a guy he basically
said you know
a lot of these networks that do you know
we celebrate black history month
first off it's like gonna be it's like
uh 12 years of slave and then soul
playing i'm like i feel like you should
divvy up these maybe
first of all second off it's they they
do that
because it's hip it's a good look for
them sure they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] and then
they don't know how many you know black
employees they have um
yeah they could be like how many black
employees do you have they they probably
like we don't know
but they they can deal here's a thing
you don't really care
it's all optics it's optics so so i'm
with you in the dishonesty i also think
like
yeah you know we're gonna guys like us
like we've been told
know a lot in the business and and
i think it's like we'll just right now
what we're making isn't hip it'll be hip
in 10 years or something right right
right yeah it ebbs and flows and i get
that i get that
it's just a bummer that if you
acknowledge that you're an [ __ ] yeah
you know so you're like i don't get the
part and i can't acknowledge
yeah well you're well you're you were
like you have like honesty tourette's
ah it's a problem which is like great
for a comic not great for
not for great for social skills right
exactly
that's my whole life baby but thank god
for comedy i can
push it into the gutter of comedy and
just get it off the roof
you're doing great thanks man you're
doing great all right moving on
i saw i caught you some of your set last
night it's hilarious oh thanks they
weren't great at the cellar though
they were a little tight yeah they're
real tight i got off and i was a little
annoyed
i mean i heard the end you were killing
i had pops but i was it was in and out
it was in and out yeah the show before
that that we did or maybe
i don't know if you were there actually
the one the night before was amazing
and so you start getting used to oh like
oh this is the this is the standard this
is how it's gonna always be and then you
have a different crowd the next night
you're like oh right it
it ebbs and flows yeah for sure i always
have to remind myself like what last
night this was murdering [ __ ] you guys
i'm like
well maybe they were too hot and this is
actually reality so you gotta remember
it's somewhere in the middle
it's somewhere in the middle i think
that's a tough thing we go on the road
and we get a little spoiled because yeah
people not only they're always a little
hotter outside of new york city
yeah and they're there for you they're
there for you and we're bringing some
new
new york juice to lexington kentucky so
i think it's i think the
the hot sauce is a little hotter for
them they're like whoa
this is crazy [ __ ] this is new york
level [ __ ] yeah but it's just weird to
come back from atlantic city and been
like now that was a crowd
you know what i mean it's just true it
used to be the opposite you should be
like a kill in new york then i go to
[ __ ] omaha and they don't get me
but also realize we're doing all new
stuff true and we perform like
if we went up there and played the hits
maybe it's a different story but like
that's not what that's not how we
roll i mean we roll by yeah you know
yeah comedy's like or stand up comedy is
like sex where you
you know you always see these marriages
like you got to spice it up you know
it's hard after a few years and i feel
like the same with
new stuff you got to spice it up and
you're like whoa i have this resurgence
of energy and passion for comedy
because you're mixing it up again if you
do the same set
that's why you see these old guys on a
cruise who want to blow their brains out
because they're doing oj jokes and
you're like if you wrote a new thing it
would bomb but then you would try to fix
it you would work on it and then it
would
you'd see some light at the end of the
tunnel then you figure it out after a
month
best feeling really it's really hard
though you know what those guys are
doing that because they're always doing
hell gigs
so when you're always doing a hell gig
and the crowd's always bad you always
got to bring
got him you always got to play the hits
i mean that's true and and it's really
hard to write a new act
when you don't have a fan base so true
because you're
you're basically what are you going to
workshop it for a place that could just
replace you like you're getting booked
because you kill
great not because you're a fan base
that's that's what's really hard
uh yeah and that's what was so hard for
us i think for years is figuring like
yes
we were bombing his no names yeah we
were bombing his guys at clubs were like
i guess i'll give you a weekend
and now at least we have enough people
coming out that they're like
they're okay with us trying something
yes they'll give you the benefit of the
doubt i already know this guy's funny
but you got to prove you're funny in
those moments that's the hard thing and
but then we also like you hear stories
about like young chappelle where he was
always doing this he was always writing
so much
yeah yeah so that's that's the tough
thing i think that's a great point about
as a young guy you gotta kill because
you're not
tried and true you like imagine trying
to make the basketball team and you miss
every free throw and like what are you
doing you're like
i'm working on new stuff you know you
gotta make those baskets
and it's the same with a young comic an
athlete just i'm [ __ ] around
dude i'm trying my hook i'm trying this
but like you got a great jumper ah
now i'm trying behind the back you know
i'm trying the alley-oop or whatever it
is well
it's kind of like the g league you're
like you're a developmental player and
you're not in the pros and you're trying
to work on [ __ ] it's much harder
because the money's worse and the
trainers are worse like all the
circumstances are worse that's what
shittier clubs are yeah it's easier to
get better when you're put in situations
where you can succeed
yes i mean that's why you see people pop
young and people like they [ __ ]
but they delivered it's like but they
were put in a situation to deliver they
had
they were all there they already had
fans so it was easier to work out
material like it's easy to work out
new jokes when they love you the second
you hit the stage of course
and obviously you still gotta deliver at
a certain point but you know
uh yeah completely that's why like
melanie is doing stand-up again and it's
all his people coming out so he's gonna
workshop this thing with
some nice cushion and i think you need
that and i think that cushion will allow
him to get crazier and weirder and
you know more outside the box and he's
divorced so he probably doesn't have
someone at home who's like what where
are you going
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah we haven't gone out to
dinner in a while
right you never take me out anymore i'm
speculating
he's one of the best i'm excited to see
us killer phil hanley saw it
yeah what do you say he said it was
amazing yeah melanie's
i think that's gonna be maybe the best
comic probably the best comic working
outside of like the legends but yeah
rock opened
true true story just there for the girls
yeah crazy though just he's gonna have
this gonna be like his prior
rock is just chilling by the bar and
they're like good said he's like thanks
yeah yeah just chilling they're both
divorced they can bond yeah dude
yeah it seems like everyone gets that
can you see a better show than
rock and melanie that's insane i don't
know
that's [ __ ] hard maybe logan paul
versus caitlyn jenner
but yeah no you're right that's a hot
show and they're both divorced they're
both
raw working on new [ __ ] i mean that's a
hot show
rock's got some new stuff that's unreal
that's like michael jordan and lebron
together yes exactly exactly the young
the young goat and then the old goat
yeah
give me a peeve oh boy i got two
but maybe i should save one but uh one
of them
ah speaking of stand up this kills me
you ever have a mediocre set or anything
in life something doesn't go well a job
interview bombs or whatever
or you dr bomb a driving test or
something like that and
everyone knows it didn't go well they're
watching you and they go how do you
how did you feel that went i [ __ ]
hate when people say i bomb
somewhere and so i get off stage and
somebody goes how'd you feel that went
and i was like
it was [ __ ] horrible you gotta make
me repeat it like you're gonna talk to
me like you're my therapist after i just
bombed
oh man i wanted to strangle this guy i
put out a video
trying to get some views on it and it
got zero it got the [ __ ] views
and he was like how do you feel like the
the reaction on that video was i'm like
the numbers are right there you don't
have to ask me
thanks for making me relive it yeah it's
no how do you think that went oh man
like they're asking you to take a long
hard look at the mirror
yes exactly you know what not well
not well i'm miserable over here the
whole thing stunk
it bombed it went through the floor
everybody hated it how do you feel it
went
look at the numbers look at the audience
look at the reaction get out of here
ah i wanted to strangle that guy as
you're strangling
how do you think you're doing how's this
going for you
right how's your esophagus feel huh
how's this going come on
you're killing me that's annoying yes
internet etiquette can be really touchy
like i
i had a guy this [ __ ] bugged me he
messaged me
he gave one of my youtube videos five
stars and writes you're welcome
oh here's the screenshot you're welcome
oh what a [ __ ]
you want credit for [ __ ] g for giving
a good review to a thing i wrote yeah
[Music]
youtube video you liked you piece of dog
yeah the free entertainment you got you
come guzzlers i hope you get
[ __ ] hit with a crowbar on the way
home yeah
oh you're welcome what up your welcome
is
never not what i can't remark never
you were a piece of dog [ __ ] you're
welcome
yeah i don't how about uh say that if
you leave my life forever
say you're welcome that's the only time
i'll thank you imagine getting blown
and you finished like that was great
you're welcome
you know come on i gave you something
you're welcome is a great thing to say
after someone blows you for
14 minutes right right are you almost
there
mm-hmm you're welcome yeah sorry to pull
my pud
for a half an hour because i couldn't
get it up but dude this natty wine buzz
is unlike any buzz can't beat it i like
you know why it's like you ever drink a
really like i drink a lot of truck stop
coffee
you ever get a really good cup of coffee
and that caffeine buzz you're like
that's a [ __ ] high right there
euphoric yeah yeah by the way truck stop
coffees if we start a coffee
that's gotta be their name truck stop
coffee sounds like it hits you like a
mac
ironic kind of like what we're going
with her around yeah you say what it is
i guess we can fat cat there you go fat
cat rye
like [ __ ] old school 20s new york
baby
loose uh tuxedo bow tie white jacket
cigarette in the ashtray we're a bunch
of nobodies so we're going to have a a
cocktail that's
you know kind of a nice and high-end
feeling i like that matt's bringing the
pictures of uh
fat cats which we cannot use we found
out they're not
legally allowed to use uh cartoon
imagery
imagery so children won't want to arrive
i feel like kids are gonna take a step
and be like not for me
uh yeah i could see i'm over juicy juice
capri sun
type of kid the joe camel rule i guess
i don't know uh that [ __ ] works though i
remember there was a mr bubble like a
laundry detergent i had batman and robin
and i was like mom we gotta get it she
was like
special needs douche get out of here
like we gotta get this one
lunchables would have someone honestly
yeah from marvel you're like mom
spiderman lunchables
come on it's gonna be better than the
other ones just like it's all the same
when some chinese company made it it's
all made out of plastic
kill yourself you ever look at the
nutritional uh facts
on unlunchables you're like this is the
least healthy [ __ ]
of all time oh yeah like how are
crackers ham and cheese this bad for you
you found a way to take it to an i don't
know what the hell you're putting in
that [ __ ]
i know i think it's like sofa cushion
insides or something and i remember
wanting that my mom was the most frugal
coos on the planet
frugal coos is a great punk band but uh
my mom was so cheap she would give me
like a grocery bag
first of all she put a jar of chocolate
milk i had to keep the jar and bring it
back home that was a nightmare trying to
keep track of a glass jar when you're
six
but i had to keep the glass jar then it
would be
uh like a tortilla with cheese in it
and carrot sticks and something else it
was the worst lunch of all time and
that's
horrible i'd see the gushers guy i'd see
the lunchables my mom never gave me any
of that [ __ ] either
yeah it always hurts yeah the fruit by
the foot guy you're like this guy's a
[ __ ]
legend everyone hates me at school i
know fruit roll up he's the guy with
cigarettes in jail i'm over here
sucking dick for a ramen noodle brutal
[ __ ] i would have killed for a little
mini bag of teddy grahams
me some cinnamon come on yeah something
i've heard of mom dunkaroos oh
that kid was a legend whoever had
whoever had the vanilla frosting
dunkaroos did yeah
i'm like mom book me a sleepover at this
kid's house his parents don't give a
[ __ ] and he knows how to live
yeah like some kid would have a can of
coke i'm like you got a can of coke
that's like having uh heroin in school
that's crazy
i got a toast for you oh please to
people who bring
positive energy wherever they go here
here
because that's hard there are people
like you do that you really do
i try i know a few people who they bring
positive salakus you do that too
i definitely do not uh but people who
bring
like shout out to anyone if you bring in
positive energy that is
like stavros does that too stav is
incredible with that
yeah i mean i'm grateful for people like
that because
i know you're slowly dying inside from
how much you're you're holding in
yeah and you're going to burst one day
and i just hope i'm not around for that
look at robin williams you know he was
the he [ __ ] come in the room doing
cartwheels and playing with he'd take a
scarf and put it around his head
i'm an old lady or whatever everyone's
laughing he gets off stage look
yeah that's what you need after you deal
i feel that sometimes i'll be at a club
and i'm like on i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] with i'm riffing up with people
i'm doing a thing second i got a stage i
just grab a shot i'm like
oh completely come on yeah give it to me
yeah i was selling shirts today taking
photos and uh the opening
takes it out of you oh my god that's
worse than the show he's like you need
another drink i was like give me two
give me a double yeah yeah you just
gotta come back
uh tequila and soda on the road on the
road i do i do a lot of like
vodka tequila soda clear
light you know not heavy the soda's
light the tequila's light it's a clear
liquor apparently it helps with
hangovers i don't know sometimes they
take a risk and order manhattan and i'm
just like you use dry vermouth
are you trying to [ __ ] hurt me man
yeah you could tell the difference are
you kidding take a sip
all right i never knew it was the
vermouth i sound like [ __ ] niles on
frasier are you kidding the palette
yeah i i can't tell i never knew it was
uh the vermouth was
was the problem oh yeah well it's it's
supposed to have it's not supposed to be
a bitter drink you know
the sweetness is what makes it in
manhattan but then uh
no you do the you do the uh driver move
through the old pal
right there you go which i i hope fact
we do some fat cat old pals that'll be
our drink at the clubs get an old pal
share with old pals are [ __ ]
underrated great drink
it is underrated i wonder why maybe it's
the name i think people just like
i think people just don't you if you
like
like i don't think people would venture
they venture out with their drinks i
think they're like that's on the menu
that's in
yeah you know it's like a kind of an
outside-the-box drink even though it's
not true
but that's what i'm saying i wonder why
it never made it into the lexicon like
uh
manhattan and old-fashioned and negroni
it's probably not as broad as an
old-fashioned or manhattan and then like
you're doing those liquors uh negroni's
going to beat it out with a campari
because you need a
gin drink on that menu too true true
oh well said that was a great little
run you had there was it yeah yeah that
was perfect
that you sounded like you owned a bar
like you were making a menu well we're
working on making a rye my friend
isn't that crazy it's so adult crazy and
it's so good
yeah i told the girlfriend she was like
you are i'm like yeah we're gonna try
we're gonna do a ride we already talked
to the distributor she was like oh my
god it turned her on
yeah pretty cool making a liquor and
then hey if things go well
down the line we'll try to make a uh a
scanned
cocktail i i mean i think that's only a
matter of time i think we're doing it
canned cocktail we get a canned old pal
can manhattan
you get a little tiny can [ __ ] i want
them serving that [ __ ] on delta to me
i want to [ __ ] i want to i want a
little i want to hear the can pop and i
want to pour it over some ice and i want
to get [ __ ]
lit up hell yeah after hopefully get an
upgrade and first class
watching some [ __ ] you know shitty
ass
shows they've got hopefully they got you
know something yeah
don't get [ __ ] up and watch blackish
is that a bad show i've never watched a
minute of it but uh i'm sure it's
terrible it's a sitcom
but some sitcoms are good what do you
love a modern family's good i bet
blackish is good
all right it's anthony anderson isn't it
i like him he's great he's great i think
he did comedy for 10 minutes
or stand up yeah i think he did a tour
he's great man yeah he's good he's in
the departed
great you hit the [ __ ] references
white role that's the only one i know
uh you're a black guy in boston you
don't need help for me to get [ __ ]
yeah
uh uh what do you got you got a wreck
i got a wreck all right this is a weird
one but
listen to this audiobook it's great it's
called the black and the blue
it's by matthew horus who uh it's he's
he's a black cop and it's just his
experience as being a black cop and the
stories are incredible like he gets
other cops to tell stories
but it's like you know he experienced a
lot of racism growing up
he also was a cop so he's he's dealt
with like you know he talks about
dealing
with opiates and making arrests and like
how they were on the wrong side of it
and how they were kind of pawns and cogs
in the system
it's really fascinating and he's uh
he's a good writer i mean he really is
like very charismatic and he's
uh from philly he's had experience with
uh police
brutality as a kid his dad he comes from
educated family his parents were
also got cut by the new york giants like
crazy life story so we made
came close to becoming a pro athlete
uh just a fascinating story uh
interesting interesting guy and seems
like a really cool guy oh there it is
oh wow look at that i'm enjoying it a
lot i'm almost done with it so he's
obviously a big dude if he was up for
the giants yeah
yeah yeah wow black and the blue oh the
black the blue
got it yeah the black and the blue okay
yeah i'm really enjoying it
i might have listened to that because i
have a bit about being a black cop you
should listen i'm listening because i
have so much new police material oh yeah
so i was listening to it i was like uh i
i did a show in arlington a black cop
walks up to me goes
love the police jokes love the black
lives matter jokes and i was like man
that's uh that's all you want to hear is
that like that's that's my demo right
there for those jokes
yeah and then uh yeah yeah i want to
make sure
i want people to think that they're that
i'm you know being funny with it all or
not
totally you want to make sure the bits
aren't pandering that's exactly
in either direction yes like our old gay
jokes
yeah yeah uh all right good wreck
what's your black and the blue and you
chose audio
book i'm well i've been walking a lot
this week i've been pretty busy so
uh you know if i if i'm home late at
night and i and i can read that's one
thing but when i'm really busy i like to
listen to either a book or a podcast
i'm with you i'm a podcast all the way i
mean audiobooks are good sometimes
they're great especially like a long
ride or a long flight it's good to have
that
continue with because sometimes a pod
has a land you're like now what do i do
you know that long audio book is i'm
reading uh stephen king's on writing
is it good it's pretty good yeah nice
i'm such a bad reader that i
i saw a tip like somebody said just read
a page a day and then you're like yeah i
could do that so then i read a page day
and then you end up reading 10.
yeah so it's all about the getting into
it with
you know people go they see the book or
they see the piano or they see the gym
and they go ah but if you just go you're
done
that's the hardest part it depends on
the book right if it's like yeah
it's like a page turner versus if it's
really dense and tough to read like i'll
there it is yeah i'll read like
sometimes i'll just read like a heist
book or like a
you know something that's so clearly
made
to be a page-turner yeah easy to read
that'll get me to want to read
more dense stuff right right but it's
just uh
i can't read fiction i don't know what
it is i like a book about writing or a
documentary or not
what do you call a biography you don't
but you watch a lot of docs too a lot of
mixes
a lot of ducks yeah yeah i went to film
school i like the way they shoot a doc i
like how they decided to put it together
and the whole thing so that's all fun
for me but uh
my wreck two things one
this is a toast more i'll i'll go wreck
them toast
wreck i don't know if you know tomas
delgado yeah great guy great guy yeah
he's a tour guide in new york
and i've always a lawyer back in the day
he was a lawyer and i think that fell
through but uh he uh he just
he does tours in new york he's and i'm
obsessed with new york i'm obsessed with
cities
and he does these uh he put him on
youtube
so he got a camera guy and he'll just go
to fort greene or brooklyn heights or
tribeca or brooklyn bridge
and he'll just give a tour on youtube so
you don't have to go walk around like an
idiot with these
losers and uh you learn about [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] fascinating and i love
fun facts
and uh they're all on youtube i watched
uh brooklyn heights today
amazing he's like that's truman capote
where he lived he wrote uh
in cold blood there norman mailer lived
there this was an old hotel
it was like the ritz carlton of brooklyn
i mean it's just
killer wow so much history so he's great
at it he's great
and the facts are actually interesting i
can see that he's very engaging
yeah he's a fun guy to talk to great guy
funny guy
and they're they're not pretentious at
all he's not like hello this we're here
on the side of you know he makes jokes
and all that and he's like that's the uh
the law firm that didn't hire me like he
throws that all in
you know so they're really well done
they're on youtube
thomas delgado you could turn this into
like a tv show or something
maybe maybe they don't have a ton of
views and i watch them at home like
these are so well done and they're just
oh man
yeah they're great and you learn things
about your own neighborhood i watched
the west village when i was like i
didn't know that that's a bob dylan
record i didn't know that yeah really
cool i can't wait to watch this
yeah i really like him so i think this
and that sounds right up my alley man
now i'm gonna give a weird toast this is
gonna you thought your black and blue
is weird yeah i don't think it's weird
i'm giving a toast too you gotta polish
that off
artificial plants damn really
i love a fake plant i think
real plants are overrated you get the
same you get the same
look do you prefer sex robots too as
long as things that aren't living
in a pinch i bring one on the road
uh i just think uh like especially those
little ones like see that one on the
right sally with the three yeah
that [ __ ] you put one on a shelf one on
your nightstand
one on the windowsill you're good to go
like that bobby darren song artificial
flowers she made artificial flowers
i don't know that one oh it's a good one
but i'm with it yeah uh there's your sex
robot but yeah
uh i just think fake plants you don't
gotta water them
you don't gotta mend and tame
and and look after them this might be a
metaphor for bigger [ __ ] in your life
yeah maybe
i grew up with a fake christmas tree
every year
sex robots you don't have to listen to
their stories
they don't cry on your shoulder yeah
yeah they just suck your dick that's all
they do
well we've all bought flowers for your
lady and they go dead in two days and
you're like wow this is weird this is
kind of pointless
yeah uh but these things they just look
great they last forever
they stay erect they're they're the way
to go you get a nice
vase or vaz or planner or holder
whatever it is
go fake plan i'm on board i i'm
i'm interested you got a real plant i
don't have any plan there you go oh you
got to get it you got to get something
green in the house it changes everything
that was the most jewish sentence i've
ever said you got to get some green in
the house
it changes everything it really does
like i'm in a video
my life was [ __ ] until i got one of
these take a look
it's a black and white video my life
sucked
you're in pajamas cut you in a tuxedo
you're in all this foliage
yeah it's uh it's a it livens up the
apartment i swear to god
speaking of uh liven up we're brought to
you by uh sheath
underwear you got that right this is i'm
wearing it right now i think i love this
underwear
uh keeps your balls off your leg two
pouches one for your dick one for your
balls
keeps the ammo separate from the gun i
love it it's supportive it looks great
but
is that i don't think that's sheath is
it oh yeah oh well i never got the camo
send me the camo color i never got that
i stormed the capitol in these it was
pretty exciting dude
you must have like you would be on like
the capital like sexy calendar
the calendar the capital calendar there
they go look at that
i just took those oh damn you look good
buddy
uh no it's uh the really great underwear
i would wear them
uh although you're like the [ __ ]
naked cowboy dude i know
we've got paid well for this that's
[ __ ] great yeah
uh the idea from sheath came from the
founder us
army soldier robert padden during the
second tour in iraq this guy is great i
mean this is really a great product
support for this uh support this awesome
veteran-owned company
whose founder is a big comedy fan mark
tell them how to do it
we love you rob best underwear in the
biz they look great they feel great
go to sheath underwear dot com and order
with promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
and sheath underwear's 100 money-back
guarantee that's sheath
underwear.com promo code drunk
go to sheath underwear and let them
support your balls
folks i'm wearing them now if they
you can't get a better endorsement than
that it's dude it's [ __ ] solid
solid the lady loves them she's like oh
my god they're so
tight in the right places and they're
stretchy in the right places
that separates the genitals i like yeah
sometimes
like you know your dick will fall out of
the yes lap and you're like ah this is
embarrassing
i know you're gonna ruin the uh the
olive garden
david tell's got that great joke
somebody goes you watch porn he goes
only at the library
that's [ __ ] great god i know it's so
unfair did you catch us
that last night uh some of it yeah
killer um all right what do you got on
you gotta
i guess we're doing bits are we doing
bits unless did we did we get we got to
pee
we got a wreck i got a couple bit ideas
that needed help i got one or two that
all right i have two cop jokes speaking
i'm sorry to go so cop heavy lately i
got a chunk i'm trying to
make it perfect here but uh so one of
them is
what the hell is this wine there's some
[ __ ] dust in the bottom oh okay maybe
i shouldn't do the bottom
yeah isn't the first time you said that
anyway uh you know
uh yeah i've won about how i was reading
until i was reading that book the black
and the blue and there was a uh
a cop who said that he pulled over a
black guy because he was driving a volvo
he goes i'm not racist it's just that's
not a normal
car for a black guy to drive and it's
like first off you you are racist
that's insane second off you're not just
doing it because it's not like if there
was an amish guy driving to volvo that's
much less
normal honey you're not pulling him over
right right maybe also like if there's a
black guy driving a horse and buggy
that's pretty [ __ ]
not normal you're not pulling him over
yeah
interesting so wait oh this is a white
guy talking
he's a white cop okay okay interesting
so the white guy is pulling over a black
guy in a vault also it's like how [ __ ]
up is it that like a black dude can't
like like like like a black dude can't
just get a like
like bentley is [ __ ] up to pull black
over we pull them over for a volvo
yeah for a sensible [ __ ] car like
that's a pretty
i'm not saying it's not like a good car
but it's like come on
why'd you pull them over too reliable
yeah it's the most reliable
you know sensible car you buy it that
car to be safe
yeah you're not safe right there you go
there you go yeah that should be that
should be if they sell a cut they should
make a car for black people
like you won't get pulled over this is
sounding a lot like segregation here oh
yeah [ __ ] you're right but it'd be
that'd be a funny ad like to to help
black people not get pulled over
you know like here's what you need to
fit the stereotype
obviously that would be yeah there's
just a white guy driving it getting
pulled over and they beat the [ __ ] out
of him yeah
yeah um no that's uh that's interesting
it's interesting to me that's like i'm
not racist this is just not normal it's
like well just that's not normal doesn't
mean it's a reason to pull someone over
right right well cops go by patterns i
think but yeah
that's true you're right that's cool a
lot of those patterns are uh
racist those uh patterns are
yeah it is a german car right now we
talk about that a lot in this book where
they say like how
they often go after black guys for the
drug trade but it was so often
white drug dealers hmm interesting
yeah so wait a minute this this bit's
good there's something here
there's something here i like this is
part of a whole chunk about
uh race and and cops and stuff i think
it's pretty funny so accused has seen me
been
working it out but i had a that was one
of the bits the other one that i can't
crack
i'm doing a double here i'm sorry do it
was
i do a thing about it hits but it needs
more
i i compare black
uh i don't know i compare cops to white
women that's the best yeah i don't know
if
i've done this in the show yeah we did
the white women thing
all right let me do a different one then
all right let's stay with this for a
second but i like
i've tried different i've tried
different angles but i want to do the
same bit even if it's a different take
on it
all right what do you got wait i don't
know i thought you had something else oh
no
let me see yeah yeah hold on hold on
wait wait wait wait i'm still on the
volvo thing really
volvo thing well talk to me that's great
uh so maybe he pulls the guy over
with a sensible car a reliable car and
then the guy's listening to
barenaked ladies or something and he's
like that's what i knew he was
something was up you know you keep going
with the uh this isn't fitting the
profile
like why the hell can't this guy just
like what he likes but then also it's
like why
like so then it's almost like cops are
saying black people have to fit into
this box
right so it's kind of like so it's like
he's not
listed but black people you're saying
black people have to fit into a box but
it's like all right so
this guy did something different it's
like almost like being unique
yes or not being unique that's not the
right word but be going
breaking away from a pattern yeah not
acceptable but it's like
isn't that what most people who are
interesting do
ah prince very androgynous
androgynous but it's interesting because
i think he's obviously saying this guy
stole this car from a white guy sure
yeah so he's following the pattern of
a lot of white guys drive this car now a
black guy's right he must have stolen it
yeah i think yeah but it wouldn't go the
other way
it wouldn't be like hey this white guy
is driving this low rider
they don't do that like i don't think
jews are getting pulled over in
escalades like
why a cadillac right exactly that's what
i'm saying exactly yeah
hmm right now it's just kind of an
interesting point and not that funny
no no but we're going to get there we're
working it out
uh salaki's wearing two different
colored socks or is that just an ace
bandage
it's a bandage you hurt your foot he's
getting old
damn he's got the goat um
oh i had something geez now you got me
looking at celica's disgusting
calves um hold on [ __ ] you're that
dude who takes your [ __ ] socks off on
the plane aren't you salacious ugh
ah that's a problem all right hold on
oh oh i got it i got it most black guys
get pulled over it's like hey you fit
the description
but in a volvo it's like hey you don't
fit the description so the black guy's
like
i get pulled over i put i fit it and if
i don't see what i'm saying
what do you mean like most black guys
get pulled over by the cops because the
cop goes hey i saw you you fit the
description of somebody who grabbed a
liquor store oh you don't fit the dinner
and now you don't fit the description
because you're driving a volvo
and i'm like so i'm getting pulled over
i fit it and if i don't i'm [ __ ]
either way
problem is you fit the description for a
crime that's the problem
yeah yeah yeah i don't know it yet go
give me one of you
later well mine is much darker
i don't think mine is dark i think it's
just an observation no that's what i'm
saying yours is not dark
way darker well i'm trying to work on
this bit about
there was a their first female school
shooter
sure so i'm like geez ladies you're
taking all our sports
you know and i'm like i mean you shot
less people
yeah but um yeah yeah you're still not
as good as the male shooters
but hey you're out there that's progress
first female
shooter but then you know it's fun that
there's the progress
in america is a female
person that kills people yeah you know
that's the joke
basically like the progress is like hey
we need more women
in this movie but like hey we got a
female shooter
that's that's something too diversity
uh yeah women are taking this anything
you can do we can do better thing a
little too far
right soon you'll have a trans woman
shooter like i'm gonna go up against the
shoot the female shooter
i don't know i don't know i think
there's something interesting about a
woman finally doing it
yeah for sure it's been a long time
coming she's the jackie robinson of
shootings
of female shootings you know
yeah there's something about
she broke the glass ceiling well
actually she shot through it ah
yes now we're cooking yeah now we're
cooking yeah yeah yeah
i like she broke the glass ceiling with
bullets and uh
i like the idea too of the the men at
the school like
what i didn't know a woman could do this
and then they get shot
or something oh yeah [ __ ] you
you go girl yeah yeah you're a pioneer
ah [ __ ] you're breaking the barriers
and my spine ah [ __ ]
first female mass shooter where was it i
was in like
sioux falls sally this is where this is
this is where you
north dakota shine is that it was it was
up upper north
area very rurally kind of area but yeah
she shot up a school oh is it cleveland
no that's not true false it's funny that
isn't that named after like
indians yeah it's funny that they're
like well who would have thought there'd
be violence in the place we stole land
from [ __ ]
also her if her name was sue and the cop
shot her like all right sioux falls
finally they shot sue maybe it was
cleveland
elementary school jesus [ __ ] christ
they start young out there you know it's
this is gonna sound dark but i'm on the
mailing list for the brady act which is
like a really good
organization uh against gun violence you
know and uh
after uh brady who is uh ronald reagan's
uh secret service who got shot oh wow
you know
and uh i get so many messages
it's like that's how many mass shootings
there are again it's like i get like two
a day from them
really yeah i mean the mass shooting you
can't even keep up when there's one
i got one this morning like six new mass
shootings i'm like i try to open most of
them like i can't read
i don't have time to read all of them
it's crazy it's our greatest export
it's not good i don't think they have
those other places do they
not like not like america but we also
have like such a [ __ ]
gun problem here i guess so yeah i mean
that's when people were saying defund
the police and then you're like and then
what
every man for themselves ooh
it's like we already have a gun problem
right i don't like the idea of every man
for themselves because i live in the
city and you guys have a [ __ ] head
start
yeah we don't have guns here yeah well
every morning i wake up to the
the news it's like two-man shot in the
bronx a lot a lot of shootings in new
york lately
a lot of shootings in new york queens
the bronx brooklyn
yeah it's wild out there yeah i wonder
if the cops in a weird way are kind of
like
oh you don't like us huh oh i'm sure
i'm sure right but it's kind of like
when your girlfriend's like i don't need
you and then she's like there's a roach
yeah someone needs to install an air
conditioner please
the summer ah yeah right exactly
and then i'm like i'm also incompetent
maintenance
[Laughter]
uh yeah you know the first female mass
shooter is she the first ever
i assume i've never heard of another
shooter
i probably this first school shooter
because patty hearst i think he shot
some people
she didn't kill anyone oh [ __ ] i tried
to give her the benefit
no she i don't even know if she's shot
she was holding there was a famous
picture of her holding the machine gun
that's all i'm going off of is that
photo
yeah she looked pretty hard in that
picture she did yeah jerked off to the
gun
jay mcinerney married to hearst the
writer oh yeah the guy who wrote uh
bright lights big city
yeah so i think he's just like he was
this [ __ ] great writer and now he's
just like
i i had to unfollow one of his social
media because it was like literally him
just getting [ __ ] up all the time
oh wow because he's just rich he's like
here's another wine i'm like
you're the best [ __ ] writer why are
you doing this yeah right
you know anything on that shooter sally
oh no multiple women doing it
oh well now i'm the bigot now i'm the
sexist because i was like we got one
there's multiple maybe that's the angle
it's crazy like yeah there have been a i
thought it was the first but it turns
out they've been a bunch it turns out
i'm a bigot
right right turns out you guys are great
at this yeah
exactly
[Laughter]
it turns out it turns out that they're
uh they're pretty good at murder
oh women have murdered a lot yeah yeah
my confidence my self-esteem
my uh my dreams
my future yeah all right well it's not
shocking that women are good at murder
because they're good at so much
other i mean like i used to have the bit
about the female mass shooter different
bit but it would be like how you never
see a female mass shooter because uh men
will they'll murder their best friend
or a stranger but they'll but women they
kill their boyfriend their husband
yes like men and women have sex the way
they they kill the way they make love
men are like i will kill anything but
women are like i gotta get to know you
first
great bit great you wanna get murdered
by me you're gonna have to put a little
work
that was a joke a different bit but uh
it was also about female mass shooters i
mean damn it's like
yeah it's rare it's rare for sure women
like a slow build you know i p i'll put
antifreeze a drop in your oatmeal every
day then after six months you're done
yeah cause i think women like foreplay
they like the idea of like
i'm killing them every day a little bit
you know
then then the death is the big climax
women want a little
a little foreplay man we really are
hitting every stereotype this episode
this one's going to get us in a lot of
trouble
that's one great thing about my gal
she's like i want to just get right to
it
[ __ ] for really yeah yeah which is great
for me because i'm like oh great i want
to get get to it too
it's like it's like a coming attraction
every once in a while you want some
yeah i came
[Laughter]
every once in a while you want a trailer
though that's true we do love a trailer
trailers on youtube have millions of
views we love
that enticing it's that anticipation
have you gone back to the movies yet
actually i haven't i can't it's the last
movie you've seen in the theater
that's a great question [ __ ] i can't
even remember i'm telling you mine right
now
please 1917. i saw that in the theater
great movie great movie great my girl
hated it she was bored out of her mind
oh it's incredible getting this
this happened a masterpiece it's about
you feel like you're in it
yeah it's [ __ ] heavy it's really it's
shocking and it's well done
so well done man shout out to sam mendes
brilliant director man
brilliant i mean uh didn't he do
american beauty oh yeah yeah
wow jarhead yeah all right
this is way better than jarhead oh yeah
your head's very slow
golf war movies like what do you what
are you gonna do it's the least
funny turnaround yeah yeah out of all
the wars you're gonna go golf
well a lot of people are like you know
there's no gulf war movie i'm like for a
reason
yeah yeah come on what are we not saying
it wasn't terrible but it's like a lot
of sitting around
yeah it's like having a movie about john
stockton i mean we got a lot of other
he did nothing against stockton all-time
steals and assist leaders
well nobody wants to watch a movie of
assists i'm sorry
i mean look the guy is great and i think
he's not true dr
kevorkian that was a movie
and a heist movie i guess is about
stealing a [ __ ] that's an assist
yeah yeah that's true yeah what do you
think about kevorkian
mixed yeah i mean like i think he was
white
all right all right i mean i think just
you know
if you're miserable and you're ready to
go
i i i i i guess it depends on the line
where you think
is murder versus assisted suicide yeah
i mean the family wants some
some input i think yeah that's the
problem suicide machine
holy 130 assisted suicides i mean [ __ ]
man
cause some cm is a hero yeah i mean
i don't know if i call him a hero but i
i don't know i think when you get to a
point where your body shuts down and
you're in hell
and you don't want to live anymore it's
your body it's your right
agreed agreed i mean sure women are
allowed to get abortions
yeah shouldn't we be allowed to shut
[ __ ] down
this is my computer can't i shut down
interesting
but some people say they're not in the
right state of mind children
either on drugs whatever well yeah
they're old they're on drugs
yeah so is there there's got to be a
dock on him that that seems like a great
compelling documentary
with him that's [ __ ] perfect what oh
he killed his career
are you killing patients i'm just
getting warmed up
i thought it was a little weird how
often he said hoo-ha in that movie
yeah won the oscar i think mr kevorkian
please step down i don't believe i will
yeah
is that you always said it's overrated
that instead of a woman yeah yeah
it's like he's doing like a black guy's
voice it's like offensive for someone
like how did you get away with just
doing like a black southern voice that's
true
yeah patina's like please step down i
don't believe i will
what the [ __ ] is that voice i know
everything works out that he shows up to
it just
he's driving a ferrari that works out
never wrecking
in new york city tango yeah he does the
tango that works out he picks up a chick
he [ __ ] her somehow then he goes to the
trial at the end
and that works out it's like standing
though
that's such a [ __ ] early 90s movie i
know
please step down go [ __ ] yourself
oh he's not a bad man we love you blind
guy
of course that we don't know it's young
phillip seymour hoffman
yeah he was great he put the gun to his
head i'm gonna kill myself charlie how
do you clean up the blood and suck my
dick he's like please
please don't kill yourself
[Music]
i'm blind yeah i'm blind as a bat
yep but i still they should make a
sequel like a darker version he takes
charlotte china down he's like
charlie i'm going to get my dick sucked
by a korean prostitute
you stand out back in man god just like
vietnam
why there's koreans in chinatown i don't
know i don't know charlie were all
confused
it's just like war time yeah yeah
oh man look at young phillip he was uh
he was cute
[ __ ] the greatest yeah if you could
bring back one actor from the dead
philip seymour hoffman
james gandolfini who are you taking
those two
out of those i'd go damn
gandolfini you love so much because he
had that big role but he and he was so
nice he like got everybody paid more but
philip i think is
is uh got more range so i'd go i don't
know what to do
he's got range i mean what is he in get
shorty
he's the man who wasn't there true
romance
yeah he was like a meat head he was like
the hit the muscle
enough said he's in a rom-com with julia
louis-dreyfus don't tell me gandolfini
doesn't have rain i'm not sitting on
that range i'm saying he's got less
range than hoffman
possibly but i still sopranos is the
best show of all time dude i agree but i
mean magnolia
[Music]
is great i love him both you're right i
love him both but he had more life in
him
too he had he was going to go further
and further whereas again if he was
already older
they were pretty similar in age i want
to say what
52. he was 52 when he died
is that right jesus christ
don't tell me gandalfine didn't have
life in it i thought he was 68.
he was supposed to be on uh the night of
too but he died
ah well what about let's get the hoffman
numbers here and then we got to wrap
this thing up boogie nights
oh man come on classic classic amazing
and along came polly he's so funny yes
he's even great in that mission
impossible incredible villain damn
yeah look they're both it's i don't know
why i pit them against each other that
was no no no no i get picked up of me
i get it uh what was the age he died
there
sally i missed that
2014. i can't do that
46. oh come on pretty young
i mean you're right though they're about
six years apart
jesus i had no idea and he's from
fairport new york which i've never heard
of damn
i never saw synecdoche uh new york i
never saw it either but
it's fun hearing a guy after a bottle of
wine says san antonio new york
sorry no no i don't care what am i a cop
but yeah yeah that's a kaufman yeah i
know he's
one of the greats genius never gets his
due i don't feel like he and john
malkovich is a [ __ ] masterpiece have
we watched it recently
like what a [ __ ] weird movie that
somehow works
unbelievable i just it's funny you said
because i just rewatched uh fear and
not fear and lowly jesus i'm drunk
what's that called uh
sunshine spotless mind yeah wow i forgot
you wrote that too
unbelievable kaufman is the best at
going into this
adaptation he goes to that part of your
brain that we can't tap
into you know when you write this
amazing bit it just hits you in the
shower and you get like just a glimpse
of that
part of your brain i feel like he's able
to go there all the time what do we need
drugs
no i think you just gotta like focus on
it and and hone that
and like learn how to get there it's
kind of like learning how to meditate
crazy they wrote on the dana carvey show
what
oh that writing staff is like louis ck
stephen colbert
steve carell uh what's that dana
carvey's so funny man what's that greek
guy smigiel damn uh what's that greek
guy
salaccus uh dinos mistopolis or whatever
he's a guy writer
yeah he's a genius michael's a genius
damn
it just proved that show proves it like
these works
networks don't get it you got the most
brilliant guys in a room
unbelievable didn't go it's all [ __ ]
and it's bad for you
george carlin yes that's a great note to
go out on
all right let's plug some dates man what
do you got uh
i forget when this is coming out but uh
not this sunday with the next
okay i'm in levity live this weekend in
upstate new york speaking of hoffman
speaking of malls oh yeah it's in a mall
but it's a good club
better food than any club in the [ __ ]
country easily
cb live in phoenix i've never been there
i can't wait i love phoenix it's the
west coast florida as this guy would say
syracuse
toledo houston philly buffalo
dayton skyline and appleton arlington
improv
brea albany west palm beach
might pop into uh key west too comedy
connection in providence madison
wisconsin
all kinds of dates come out say hello
buy a shirt listen to the pod tell a
friend get on the patreon what do you
got there sloppy jalopy cincinnati
madison okc nashville
levittown new york of governors i got
comedy off broadway in kentucky
and i'm just getting warmed up like
i got uh kansas city missouri portland
helium
[ __ ] comedy castle we're a local in
my favorite rooms
laugh boston philly moon tower in austin
texas you kept bitching me to come to
texas
i might even add a little houston dallas
one night or action so keep your [ __ ]
eyes open
i got uh all kinds of [ __ ] coming st
louis helium
more samurail.com shows yeah mark
normancomedy.com also
and uh yeah great app this [ __ ]
kicks like a mule and uh i got a good
buzz going maybe we'll do a patreon and
see what happens
you gotta get on it email us bye bye
oh patreon.com we might be drunk pod and
emails that we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com we should say that too
send us rex love emails whatever you got
jokes
drinks you name it and fat cat rye on
the way
tell a friend it's coming baby it's so
good i can't wait for you to try it oh
so
tasty and affordable yes keep drinking